so I mean I have a million questions so
I I'm very curious how a John Wick movie
is actually made so I want to go back in
time it is the John Wick 3 comes out big
hit
Lionsgate calls you I guess or there's a
meeting and they say we want to do a
fourth what exactly happens there to get
to the screen in terms of you know how
are you crafting your action set pieces
how where are you thinking about you
know like locations can you sort of take
me through sure how this all got figured
out it's um
yeah I wish it was a little bit more
systematic but it does happen like that
you know the movie comes out it does a
certain degree of success you get the
call you have the congratulatory Zoom
caller yeah good job we're awesome it's
great it's worth
um then you get the well what do you say
and it's kind of a joke what do you say
let's jump right back in and you get the
next one and you're just like
because like you feel all this weight
and pressure on you it's not that you
don't want to it's just like eat okay
everyone starts trying to plan and like
it's hard to plan an idea it's like you
can't just go Tuesday five o'clock
we're going to come up with good ideas
like it doesn't happen that way so I I
get kind of resistant like yeah I'm not
ready to talk about that yet and like
and they just kind of like well well you
know it's like no you're not hearing me
I'm not ready to talk about that yet
hang up and then it was probably
four and a half five months later uh in
Japan they released a little bit later
we we've always had a delayed release
there so Keanu and I we haven't seen
each other in a couple months and
everyone's done other projects or
something like that we'll get on the
plane we'll head over to Japan like
we're gonna do in this way sure and then
I think it's twice now but on John week
3 we're in in the Imperial Hotel in
Tokyo they have a brilliant Scotch bar
there and Camera are like yeah that
was a rough one let's let's not do that
again yeah let's not do that again that
was
um good way last a good way that was
good good experience great experience it
was great okay great great great yeah no
I know it's good it's done it's really
no we can rest now it's great don't know
if we can do that we're getting older
yeah I know let's create one more one
step one more drink okay yeah
I got an idea
and that's how it always starts and
we're like we love Japan we're like
wouldn't it be cool if we did an Osaka
Continental like yeah it would have been
cool but that's that's done and at the
time I literally think I had watched
Good the Bad the Ugly on the way over I
was like I got an idea
let's have three like you know we did
the John Wick story let's let's see the
world from different perspectives let's
see it from the high table side but
we'll do a new sheriff in town we'll do
a western and at the time I was also
super in his out to each I watched like
10 in a row right and I was like yeah we
gotta have a blind swordsman he's like
blind swordsman I'm like yeah I'm blind
swordsman and I had also just watched
David lean's like you know Lords Of
Arabia I'm like we got to go back to the
desert we love Morocco we gotta go to
akaba Akbar by land we just started
thinking and laughing like I'll come by
land no blind swords but not after you
were gonna do it in Osaka Samurai yeah
that'd be great but was it hey even shot
a bow now let's do booze and arrow and
they were like John Wicked nunchucks and
you start ripping these ridiculous ideas
and they all go into this little
notebook that I carry around cut two we
get back to LA I'm like
maybe those were good and you go to the
Whiteboard and you start going numb
chucks and that's all you have
and you write Lawrence of Arabia Aqaba
and you Circle it and then you go oh
Trilogy character uh Good the Bad the
Ugly you know we'll have a blind
swordsman meets a guy that's a Tracker
like I have a dog we'll put a dog and
you start drawing these circles and
that's kind of how it started and then
we didn't have an overall plan overall
plot overall story we just knew John
Wick has to realize what he's done like
he's we keep talking about consequences
we got to see real consequences and John
Wick has to learn but he can't just say
I've learned and I want Redemption you
gotta see the pain on his face because
we're a show don't tell kind of movie so
we wrote the scene and ended up being
the hero Yuki scene on the roof where
there's that one great line one of my
favorite lens movies like friendship
means little when it's convenient
and that's when it hits John like well
he's actually
burden somebody like he somebody's going
to pay the cost of it until Rina tells
him you don't understand what you've
done you because of your my dad's
gonna pay an innocent in this and that's
we just want to keep hitting Kiana's
character with that so we knew that
theme was there like how does everybody
John bumps into he kind of he kind of
screws up a little bit because he keeps
putting this burden on him John Wick
shows up at your door John doesn't think
of the burden he's putting on you and
then halfway through the movie we wanted
John to realize like oh yeah this
is a bad thing I got to do something
good and we had to make him earn that by
actually you know letting him take the
bullet at the end for Donnie that kind
of thing so we knew we wanted that theme
and we knew we wanted nunchucks and dogs
and cars and it's funny I actually
I I've always been a fan of like some of
uh Joe Rogan's podcast but I end up
bumping into him at the gun range once
and I was like hey how are you doing I'm
the guy that does Jay he's like I'm Joe
Rogan like yeah you know he's like he
didn't even miss a beat he's like what
happened to all the muscle cars like
we're the muscle cars I'm at Taryn
Butler's gun range we're just and
he keeps here like I love muscle cars
man like great movie but what are the
cars so I wrote In The Notebook put
muscle car back in Joe Rogan hates me
and uh you know we're like okay I'm like
Joe what car would you put in
excuse me like 71 Barracuda didn't miss
a beat 71 Barracuda like all right so
everyone barracuda's going in the movie
and then you figure ways to put that in
and I think that's a lot of how we do it
on John Wick the overall created part
starts with this giant white board like
I've told you before we put down all
these ideas good the bad the ugly and
Leone's uh tuichi you know one car why
use Reds more like you know that just
came up like in the mood for love uses
Red's well makes sorrow put red more in
and it starts like that
um my dad's a plumber or was a plumber
that was his business and I remember
when I was very young I saw one of these
water curtain things happen like it came
on and off it was
you're like that's the coolest thing
I've ever seen that use that so you do a
little research I'm like ah 40 years
later I'm putting water curtains in 44
waterfalls in a dance club to to techno
music
and I just thought like that's how it
starts with all these ideas then you go
to account what do you love I you know I
want to be back on the horse I think
John Wick needs to tied together like
this I think we need to include all
three films and wrap them up and he
looks right at me and doesn't miss a
bead and he goes
jungle's gonna die
like John Wick has to die like whoa you
want to kill a character he's like I'd
say John I said John John mccasadati has
to half like that was our whole we got
to hang our hat on that like we're gonna
just it don't care who's upset by
it we're gonna we're gonna do it okay
well that's how we'll start writing the
story and we wrote backwards from that
point on to get there like what's a
deserve death what makes him think he's
gonna take that bullet and that's how we
went back every step of the way to
design the scenes and it kind of just
stated like that as far as action goes
um there's a couple of scenes we were
scenes that we had written that we cut
out like I'd love to do an underwater
sequence like a Thunderball I wrote town
like one of the earliest Thunderball
beat beat Thunderball do underwater
spirit gun sequence with John Wick style
you're like okay How's that gonna work
so I went actually to Lanai and I went
to this famous dive spot in Hawaii and
it went down underneath to to Cathedrals
they call it and you know you sit
underwater you wait for the light to hit
and at 60 feet it's just okay so I'm
going to shoot at Cathedrals I'm gonna
shoot in Hawaii we're gonna get 60 stunt
guys and we're out to Thunderball so
that went in the script
um it was supposed to be off malta's
coast and stuff because we have this
nice Templer idea and then we're like
snowmobiles in the city snow blood looks
cool in snow so do a lot of snowmobile
stuff and we're like we had a snowmobile
Chase in it we're like okay that didn't
and then you're like Arctic
gunfight in traffic boom and we started
reverse engineering that out and all
everything I'm talking about it seems
like it comes up but that that right
there is about six months I'm just
screwing around with scenes and story no
script just we'll write a scene like we
wrote the blue scene very early on we
just love the idea of being in front of
the Wrath of Medusa and the cost of
tyranny and you know how this French
thing we knew we wanted to call the guy
the Marquis he was the new sheriff in
town like you know it's like high noon
we wanted not a high table member but we
wanted
you know who who Who's the sheriff who's
gonna clean up this mess who's going to
come down and lay down the law we're
like we're gonna call that guy the
Marquee and he's gonna have this little
sheriff's badge and that's where you see
the pin in the movie the whole time like
you know you're the new sheriff here's
the here's the thing and you know we
kind of took a lot of the John Ford
Leone Western Vibe and mix it together
with Asian Cinema and that's how we kind
of got the vibe which is really like the
first half of the movie so I'm curious
what is it like to go into the studio
and say to them so Wick we're gonna kill
him off in this movie
um got a lot of faces we got a lot of
it was I mean I I have a very good
relationship with Lionsgate they're
great they've been very supportive
um but I I don't think any exact or any
producer in the world
would smile when you say you're gonna
kill off their successful franchise
character
um
so there and again I but you know I I
try to like you know and you want to
have that confrontation like look this
is what's right but you got to see it
from their side too and you go yeah like
you know I'm the guy that pitched you
know nine years ago hey I'm gonna
actually start by killing a puppy and I
gotta shoot 80 people in the face over a
puppy and I'm gonna kill Alfie Allen and
then that's it oh but the bad guys kill
his wife no she died of a disease like
that's a hard pitch John Wick never
pitches well on paper you know like I'm
gonna do ninjas on motorcycles I'm gonna
like it doesn't read well so when you
read yeah and then John Wick dies and
gives his life for the you're like what
wait wait back up what
so you try to understand
their perspective on it and they're like
look I get it it's in the execution like
it's going to be a longer movie it was
135 page script we knew we were going to
be in the two half two and a half hour
mark at least we're like look let me
give it a go and I want to do your solid
like we have this Duality thing going on
John and John Wick so like look you
whether you look at it or not as John
Wick said or John and John wicker dead
or it's a split and maybe one's off
somewhere on a desert island whatever
however you want to interpret that but
you know let let me try let me try to
execute let me try to execute it the way
we are let me build the story around it
and I'll do you solid I'll tell you I'll
shoot the ending two ways you know with
one extra little thing two extra little
shots
I'll let you know he's live and I'm
going to leave it up to the honestly
decide and we're going to test both and
they were super cool they let me go
through the whole movie
they let me you know devise the whole
script based on this ending of the
character kind of thing is demise uh his
death and why he dies and that's really
what what the movie's about
and I'll do it two different ways and we
tested it and we all looked at it and
you know the the test audiences
definitely had had a favorite of that
which is the the ending that you guys
saw and it was nice to show the student
get actual feedback about like you're
right like this is really strange but it
misses the punch it misses the ending
and makes the whole movie worth it
you know in the cathartic kind of way to
end like we did and everyone was very
understanding of that and it was
it it was good to come to that
conclusion together without having to
fight you to force it and as you can see
obviously they're they're supportive of
the ending the kind of one it was but it
it wasn't an easy sell it had to be
proved and even like we felt it was the
right direction to go but you don't you
don't know until you sit in that room
with three four hundred people and you
really feel it do you think that
everyone was in a good mood though
because John saved another dog do you
think that also helped Elevate the score
yeah I'll take whatever I can get if
that if that was a little bit of a
emotional manipulation that could have
been in there I'm not gonna say
um yeah I'll take what I can get on that
one uh so for people that are gonna
because I'm sure there's gonna be people
that ask is John Wick official like in
your perspective he is dead I think
um again not to be evasive we've always
seen like this has always been a
campfire tale right it's meant to be a
myth it's not meant to be a movie it's
not to meant to be a story or plot it's
meant to be a little bit of tale a fable
right and fables are always interpreted
because the ending's always up like what
are you getting out of it what's the
moral of story so we're going to treat
this like what's the moral of the story
with John Wick is Jon really dead well
John Wick is
I mean that's his Redemptive story now
does that the myth of John the character
of John in his little world did he find
a cool way to end that that chapter so
he could start a new somewhere else in a
different life I don't know that's an
interesting concept I'm going to leave
you with that one you know my personal
opinion is is probably a little bit
darker than that but like I think that's
a very open to interpretation kind of
thing and we kind of wanted it that way
so if this was a a Greek myth you'd kind
of get like okay it doesn't really
matter
which side of a diet or if he died as a
human being it matters that the John
Wick Persona died there is an after the
credit scene
um how did you decide on that scene it's
funny like we shot that there's a real
scene that goes along like Donnie coming
up you think he's got it and then Rina
goes and
gets them and then there's this whole
death scene with Donnie Yen dying like
we had a whole thing where you actually
see the demise but like it was a little
it was kind of a bummer but like not
that we like John wicker hardcore like
kill them all you know that kind of
thing and but we watched and I kind of
felt like well that's
that's not as cool as not knowing like
does Rina go down that road like you
know we have John Wick and his demise
and we are well let's open the door to
the new John like who's the new and
we're like the Kira you know she's got
the motivation she gave John the
ultimatum John chose not to honor that
but he chose to honor something much
bigger so
we had this whole scene and we're like
well that doesn't really say what we
want it was a little too much and we
didn't think it was really nailing it so
we're like well my editor Nate orloff
had a nice idea I was like what if we
don't see it what if you leave the
audience to that what's the choice right
now the choice she opens a knife but
does she actually you know hit Kane with
it and we're like that's awesome let's
just try it so we put it at the end it's
like okay we want to be a little you
know hard-boiled in our in our in our
filmmaking with John Wick but at the
same time I don't know let's leave it
open let's see what a choice and it had
that little bit of all right that was
cool and it had that little punch to it
we're like not too much not too little
and you still don't know so did she go
down that dark Road or did she kill uh
not my battle okay uh with this being
the last chapter
um have you and it might be too early
but have you had conversations with the
studio about doing a special John Wick
box set of in finding extras you have in
The Cutting Room floor all that stuff
there's been a little talk about it with
marketing and stuff I think their their
main focus is trying to get the movie
out there and do their thing but um Josh
orrick's company narrator has done a
great job I mean they have hundreds of
hours of behind the scene footage and
training from all the movies from very
very early on
um I think this talk of doing a little
bit of a special like an hour special or
featurette which is literally all four
movies you know from the beginning kind
of tracking you know for my younger days
to what I look like now and the Keanu
and how we all limp now and all that so
I think it's a very interesting they
show me some of it and it's very very
cool
um hopefully they'll tie that in with
the whole marketing scheme but I I would
love to see it just for my own interest
and I know there's a lot of talk about
you know the Video Game World the anime
world and you know hopefully the TV
world yeah um I I really am wondering
why there hasn't been like an amazing
John Wick you know um open world kind of
game I think they were just waiting for
the right opportunity and again I think
people always trying to play you don't
know if you've got something you want to
invest until it does well by the time it
does well now you're you know a
three-year leeway to get to the game to
vote so I I think um Lionsgate in
general kind of knew they wanted to go
down that road so I think for the last
couple years they have been working very
intently on it and I think they're
moving forward with something right now
uh yeah I need that just throwing that
out there the four John Wick movies have
spectacular action and each movie has a
set piece that is it looks impossible to
pull off right so I'm just curious how
would you rank in the four movies like
what do you consider the the five
hardest sequences that you had to pull
off good question good question
um
the concept we use ago like a little
trick for all the choreographers out
there
it's very easy to come up with easy
ideas does that make sense open space
there's nothing in your way so you can
you think you can do anything you know
we'll clear out the room don't don't
want that table there because then I
can't do my spin hook kick in the
the opposite is actually true the more
obstacles you put in the way the more
interesting the choreography is think of
Jackie Chan like you and I can do a
decent fight scene but if I handcuff us
together yes it makes everything harder
for both of us it makes harder to shoot
but if you nail it it's 10 times more
interesting if you want something more
interesting be subversed if showed in a
different way that's why we do the
different lighting the different things
like Marcus Aurelius right stoicism the
obstacle is the way I learned that from
Jackie Chan very early on I said how do
you he's like make it hard if it's easy
to choreograph don't do it okay that's
sorry super bad Jackie Chan
impersonation but like he he always make
it as difficult as you can like of
course you you but then you're like well
how do you're not supposed to know
because you haven't done it yet so make
it as hard as you can and the
interesting part is how you solve it
it's not the problem it's the solution
and the true judge of character is how
you solve it so choreography should
always be uh this inclusion of obstacle
or or or hardship and how you solve it
that's what makes it memorable right
like it's always like that so you take
that with the scenes and like look yeah
it's not hard to put car stunts and
fights together but it is hard to
execute there's a lot of there's a
reason people haven't done that before
because it's hard so we're like all
right well if that's our model let's see
how bad we can screw ourselves let's say
dogs cars people and like let's just try
to run anybody over kill anybody and
let's put it all together or like let's
try to do an entire 100 move sequence
from the top I move Cameron a tiny
little space over and through walls and
let's but wait a minute that'll take
thinking oh well
okay let's think and I think that's a
challenge and it'd be funny the smart
creative people the more challenges you
give them the more they get turned the
more they get inspired the more they
want to work hard at it so if you had to
have me rank all that
um every sequence we do has some little
hint like that some we can afford bigger
stuff some we can't I think out of the
four the most logistical where I was
like okay please don't mess this up
would definitely be the arc to Triumph
sequence just because I have my lead
cast member as good as he is in a car
he's driving against five Lanes of
traffic if any one person messes up at
35 45 miles an hour that's never a good
thing like movie non-movie we've made it
as safe as we feel good candle spend all
this time driving we have the best stunt
drivers we've ConEd off we've come up
with all these safety factors but things
can obviously it's moving Vehicles
things go wrong
um and then you have Shield lead actor
with with Marco our other lead you know
running through five Lanes of like you
do not and that's those are real buses
those are real cars like you do not want
to hit your lead cast with a tour bus
always goes in bad column for directing
don't run over lead actor so that that
was every time behind Mark and you're
like you don't ever want to get real
instance you never want to get relaxed
even though you got the best and you've
done it it's your fifth day of shooting
and everything's gone off hitch you
never want to just get complaints and go
ah you know we've been doing like you
can't ever like if I'm not stressed out
overseas because I get nervous because
that's when you get lazy and when you
get lazy that's when you make mistakes
so you got to be switched on
and after two weeks of being switched on
it's it's a little exhausting and
I I guess it's nice to see that it all
comes together but you don't know that's
at the end so you're like did I just
risk all those people did I just do all
this work not to get a good sequence but
you don't know to the effects are in
until the cars are into your edit and
the music's in you're like okay it was
worth it so that one was definitely in
the top five for sure
um I'd put the Top Shot in there just
logistically trying to figure out okay
how are we going to do this like there's
so much math going into where you have
to put the camera the camera to subject
how do you get one lens to do it all
without cutting and all that stuff
um mirror room and number two very
difficult just just like how do I we had
to put each of those mirrors on a 10
degree tilt swivel so we could always
hide camera because we couldn't afford
visual effects at the time there's like
two or three video effects wipeouts but
most of it is we had to hide camera
people and crew with little angles and
just you want to think about like math
is not my strongest subject and you're
going to figure that out
um another top five would be the Halle
Berry and number three with the dogs uh
dogs I mean as well trained as they are
it's dogs and they're
the dogs don't know it's a movie so
they're they're biting crotches they're
going for the Target and you just hope
that they bite the target if not the
person holding the target
um that gets a little stressful you know
yet Hallie and there's so much going
like no one's ever done that with dogs
before no one's had 50 stunt guys and
your lead Halle Berry shooting guns and
all the stuff and the dogs jumping over
people and like literally biting and
taking down something like that's a real
animal going at its fastest speed being
its most ferocious taking guys down like
that's
that's not a stunt that's a real event
like that you know that's not fake
that's those dog hits are real you know
obviously when you're hitting guys with
cars or anything like that's you know
gravity works that's a thing physics are
real you know that's not that's not
fakery that's you know we're our best
guys getting hit by our best stunt
drivers with you know 2 000 pounds of
metal that always makes you go okay so
those car hits on the Arts are trying
for real those dog hits are real
so what do we got Arctic Top Shot the
Halle Berry sequence with that and um
what's the other one
um
oh our mirror room was pretty tricky so
excuse me fifth what would that be um
wow I mean the waterfalls are always
tricky with the club we've talked about
that like that's always a logistical
nightmare
um when you deal with so many extras and
stuff but um
God I I think I like putting you on the
spot like yeah I know it's good it's
good it's making me think
you know the horse Chase in Brooklyn on
number three was a little little tricky
because you don't know how that's is
that gonna look really really ridiculous
or is that gonna be
cool
um
you know fighting with the sumo guy
fighting with the the glass houses I
mean they're all tricky but like uh for
myself what was I didn't know if it was
going to work um and which I think is
the best fight for number three which
was the knife fight and it sounds like
oh that one didn't look that hard I I
think conceptually it made me nervous
because
in every movie you see a guy throw a
knife and it sticks in and kills a guy
right off the bat and that whole purpose
of that fight was to be completely
subversive and go yeah knives don't
always stick in and what what does a
snowball fight look like with with
knives and I think conceptually we're
all nervous like this isn't yeah we're
gonna we're people gonna think this is
ridiculous they're gonna think he's
terrible so I was a little stressed out
about that one
um executing it wasn't that bad but
conceptually I was like I'm either gonna
hit or miss with this one it's either
gonna be the coolest fight in the movie
or it's gonna be the weirdest so I'm
kind of happy it turned out to be to be
good I definitely want to talk about the
Paris stairway sequence
um I think people they put that one in
the top six yeah first of all the
sequence is crazy but for people that
that maybe think that this is all like
you guys use like CGI and stuff like
that all those are real stairs that's
actual sacrifice yeah exactly so my
thing is that are these people that are
uh go you know what I mean going down
the stairs real guys all real yeah
um how exactly are people getting up
from that
this stunt guys we did a gr uh my son
great job putting together a
multinational stunt team on this great
martial arts stuntman great fight guys
and great um physical gag Guys Fall Guys
basically and you know from the 8711
team to our Japanese team to our
preaching team to our Bulgarian team
just really great guys and technology
advanced so much like they use gel packs
over hard elbow pad we have this almost
Kevlar level
um padding body armor that we can put
under the gel pack so the guys can be
staying in but you still have to go down
the stairs and get hit by the car but it
keeps the edges off a little bit so it
it does help
um but it is still going down 100 steps
like when you see that elongated stair
fall that Vincent does can stunt double
um he did that in first take he didn't
even make it down the first step and got
hung up on the railing and the way he
took off like you can see and they were
like he he goes he's like here we go no
fear
um he had to do that twice and on the
second one that take that you see in the
movie that is there's no stitching it is
a hundred percent real we cut when he
stopped rolling it is uh the second take
all in no digital effects other than
wiping out the the camera that was
tracking down it was on a cable cam so
we actually brought the cable down and
the guys on the control trying to keep
up with Vincent so you don't know
because you that's a hard one to
rehearse you just kind of go I think
this is gonna work you run radius at
three two one let's go
um so what he did on that was just go
and like that was literally human Talent
Vincent put on very standard stunt gear
and just had the heart of a lion and
just went okay I'm going and I'm gonna
make it uh
I wasn't but some of the study might
have been betting on how many steps he
would have made and no one no one
thought he was going to make it down
past halfway and he went just past
halfway he went about 65 percent of the
way down the stairs oh to 220 steps and
he did it on on the second take pretty
impressive it's actually CR I I majal
was you know this one of those things
that's the thing about the John Wick
movies is that every one of these I'm
always like you know the jaw goes down
and but I think that's one of the
reasons why like the world loves these
movies is because you guys are
constantly doing stuff like that
otherwise you get bored right without
complication is boredom I guess I'm
gonna end this with um we've talked a
little bit but um about what you want to
do next this is obviously this movie
makes it that you're literally gonna do
something else because well you are
um so what for fans of yours what do you
think might be next um like look the
John Wick
property is always interesting to us
there's always different ways to go and
we're always working with Lionsgate to
try and come up like okay how do we
continue this great journey we're on so
there's I'm always open to that whether
it was TV anime a continuation of the
John Wick franchise whatever like that's
always on the table we're always happy
to help out with that
um I have a couple great properties
going on right now I'm attached to Black
Samurai with with Netflix and with
Rainbow Six with Paramount and Michael B
Jordan which is super exciting
um and then uh you know goes to sushima
which is
um you know I can't say enough good
things about just even the story that
that that property has to it if you told
me tomorrow I had to do any one of the
three I'd be very happy to jump right in
and go you know I'm sure you understand
Hollywood has much to anybody it's that
magic algorithm of cast availability we
have a property that we think is the
probability service is very high timing
works out timing is good resource is
great we have everything we let's go and
somebody to say agree and on all those
properties we have all these things
going forward plus there's a bunch of TV
things I'd love to jump into the TV
World a little bit and try that but um
you know my heart's really into the
three properties I just talked about
because one's more of a Sci-Fi thing
more worlds more is one is a a real life
kind of chance to expand on something
that would be ours and one is you know a
love letter to everything I know about
martial arts and Samurai and subversive
storytelling and you know basically
making an art film about everything I
love
so that that's where kind of my head's
at on that note I just want to say a
sincere thank you for making these
movies and I really I'm being serious
thank you and I really look forward to
whatever you do next thanks man and
thank you guys for your support